in silence
they grieved no one could doubt the
impact
matt ratner made on east grinstead rugby
club
in just three years as head coach
a whole other world to his role as a
police sergeant
he was such a key member of our
management team and our
our playing and coaching staff
i don't think we'll be able to replace
him there's no he was one in a million
and i know people say these things but
he really was
matt rachner oversaw the training of
players of all ages
including 500 children some as young as
four
who too fell silent tributes have been
paid here as officers who've lost their
lives in the line of duty
are remembered on national police
memorial day
sergeant ratner was the eighth officer
to be shot dead in the uk
in the last 20 years
metropolitan police commissioner dame
cressida dick
was among those who laid a wreath in
their memory the day was also marked
with a service
held online due to the pandemic which
included a tribute from the prince of
wales
the dreadful incident in croydon on
friday
is the latest heartbreaking evidence of
the risks
faced by our officers daily
as part of the memorial lizzie harper
the wife of pc andrew harper
who was killed last year lit a candle
now she's joined forces with another
police widow
to call for more support for those whose
loved ones have been killed while on
duty
i mean i sent leslie a letter or a card
very early on with my details in it
and if i was in a position to i'd do the
same with matt's family
i just think that the idea of having
somebody that's been there and done it
and fully understands you might just
help you through those really difficult
dark days
for these first team the loss of their
friend and coach
has been hard to comprehend there aren't
many middle-aged people
still trying to play competitive rugby
and my inspiration for that
came from from that he was a
he had a way of inspiring people the way
he was with players with
his little blocks of wood that he
pretended with players the
sketches on the bar and he had so much
inspiration
uh it's going to be it's going to be a
real hard time without him
the more that emerges about matt whether
as rugby coach or colleague in the
police
the more clear it becomes what an
extraordinary man he was
and how keenly he would be missed emma
birchley sky news east grinstead